do you want free stuff just for playing
games on your Wii U and 3ds Club
Nintendo might have closed down last
year but the new my Nintendo rewards
program is live in Japan so we're
getting our first look at some of the
swag you can earn my Nintendo offers
gold and platinum points gold for buying
digital games and platinum for
completing certain objectives like
linking your accounts or signing in to
miiverse regularly these points can then
be used to get new games discounts and
3ds themes the first wave of prizes
includes games like the new legend of
zelda twilight princess pit cross for
1,000 platinum points and donkey kong
country returns for 320 gold points
nintendo says this is more than just a
traditional rewards program it's more of
a way to reward users for their loyalty
across several products my nintendo is
live in japan alongside Nintendo's first
mobile game me tomo both of those are
coming to North America and Europe by
the end of the month when they launch
you'll hear about it from GameSpot will
tell you all about those sweet prizes